angel is in Minnesota if a person has
never had that will they have a credit
report mm could have there's someone
that could have reported you to the
credit bureau or a file can be set up
all they need is one piece of data to
get excited to set up a file on you the
one piece of data could be your social
security number it could be an address
it could be a place of employment and so
someone anyone that reports to the
credit bureau could have established a
file for you because it's not a the that
that's the weird thing that a lot of
consumer advocates like myself and for
that matter the government has been
concerned about is that FICO Equifax
TransUnion Experian they there's the
three credit bureau of national credit
bureau reports reporting agencies they
gather data on you without your
permission and sell it and make money on
it and you know that ought to be a
little bit disconcerting and then they
turn around and make you happy that they
did that because they turned around made
the FICO score the way that you get to
do anything in our culture you know
people worship at the altar of the great
FICO but you know if you stop and think
about people have said about Facebook
using data your data without your
permission to do weird stuff and selling
that data and setting up their algorithm
in such a way that it's feeding to
certain advertisers people are all up in
arms about that they called little
what's-his-name before Congress over
that right it's a kid's name is starting
the thing I can't remember now anyway it
doesn't matter but in the you know
Facebook everybody's upset about
Facebook what nobody's thinking about
the credit bureau the credit bureau is
not a government institution it's
private business collecting data on you
without your permission and profiting
from it and we've been doing it for 30
40 years oh and by the way 52 percent of
the credit bureau reports have errors in
them
so not only do they collect data on you
and profit from it it's wrong the data
is wrong and they screw up your life in
the process and in order for you to get
them to correct your data that they
collected on you without your permission
you have to go through an unbelievable
amount of Hoops and get it all corrected
nobody ever thinks about that this is
just kind of like wrong like morally
wrong you know if I just came over to
your house and started collecting stuff
from you and sold it I think people
might get upset about that and that's
kind of what they're doing I mean
they're stealing your identity and using
it for their benefit I didn't offer them
my social security number how is it that
they got permission to use that without
my permission I didn't give them my home
address how is it that that got on there
without my permission and oh by the way
it's wrong did you ever think about that
I mean if any anybody else did that
they'd be a you know so hammered under a
spam law or they'd be hammered under
some kind of law that says you stole my
identity and used it for your benefit
and so yeah I'm can you tell I'm not
real fond of this system main reason I'm
not real fond of the system is that it
has become so closed looped that you you
know it's made to where your car
insurance is more expensive without
doing it you can't borrow money without
doing you can't rent an apartment
without doing it can't get a cell phone
without doing it you can't rent a car
without doing it it's just a pain in the
butt and I don't have a FICO score lots
of people do it without any trouble if
you've got enough money it doesn't
matter and the money I just do every
want work around it but when you're semi
broke and you don't have a credit score
it's it's bigger it's a bigger hassle
than walking around the credit score
it's almost like the mark of the beast
you know or something you know I'm not
saying that it it's tongue-in-cheek for
you theology people that are going into
eighth mode right now I mean you're
going nuts but you know seriously there
was a thing that came out that they were
gonna like put an implant in your hand
to scan instead of your credit card now
that one's a little theologically scary
right there and you have to have it to
buy and sell goods have you ever read
revelations really I mean but I mean I'm
not gonna get too freaky on you but it's
a little
or well in if you think about it more
than a little bit more than a little bit
if you're upset about Facebook maybe you
ought to think about Experian in FICO
and TransUnion and so on
you know something to think about so
there you go anyway you probably do have
a credit bureau report and you don't
even know it you may not have a score
because there may not have done any
credit transactions by which you could
be scored and that would be or if you
haven't done any in a long time and you
have no accounts open of any kind you
have a zero score that's what I have
proudly my score is undeterminable to
which they sent me an email and asked if
I was dead I thought that was a threat